james starts off this hour in tampa
florida hi james welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey dave and dr d how are you guys great
man how can we help
so my question for you guys today is
i am planning on proposing to my
girlfriend
uh in the coming year congratulations
and
i appreciate that really excited we've
been together for about
three just over three years now um
and so yeah just ready to take that next
step forward i started looking at rings
and things like that
and my question though is so i
i am debt free but she has quite a bit
of
debt and so i'm trying to figure out how
to start planning for that after you
know we get engaged we get married
combined bank accounts and all that
stuff
how do i plan to tackle her debt for
basically going back from baby step
four to baby step two well that's
exactly what you'll do
whatever money you have in savings when
you come home from the honeymoon you
will throw it at
the debt snowball and then the two of
you will combine your households
your incomes and uh you're you know
you're going to work her debt off then
the two of you
and so how much debt has she got
uh it's probably going to be around six
i guess
55 to 60 000 okay
and what's her attitude about all that
uh well it's funny you asked that i've
been trying to
to ease this conversation in with her
um and trying to talk about or kind of
have that dream conversation that you
guys talk about a lot and haven't
had that conversation yet um but she's
on board with it but she
she does not believe that i said we can
do it in less than five years
and i told her i said okay well you know
jump on board with me and you know but
we'll do it under five years i can
promise you that and she doesn't believe
me
but wait wait what is your what is your
income
so my i make about fifty thousand
dollars with commission
so this year will probably be around 65.
what's she made she's a nurse
she's a nurse probably makes 50 to 55
000.
okay so here's a simple thing that a
nurse can do
anybody can do okay is you make a
hundred thousand
if you put if you put thirty thousand
out of a hundred on your debt you're
debt-free in two years
exactly and uh that's exactly my point
and if she if i mean if you have that if
you say that sentence
and she rolls her eyes then you've got a
problem
right and i think i i
i'm wondering how you've been with
somebody for three and a half years
and you're still and you're about to buy
an engagement ring
and you're still tiptoeing around any
conversation
like there you don't tiptoe around a
dreaming conversation brother you've
been together for three and a half years
like what is stopping you from sitting
down and having that that should be a
point of joy and a point of coming
together not
some sort of apprehensive moment why are
you waiting to have that conversation
i really don't have a reason i just i i
just haven't done it to be completely
honest
give her that gift that's a gift to any
prospective spouse
male or female for the other person to
sit down and say i want to dream
together with you
that's awesome man that's a good place
and as dave said this is a math problem
and another thing a nurse can do
especially in this universe is
work saturdays for another nine months
and make a whole bunch of extra money
and you can do something on the side and
y'all could take that two
two years and cut it down to 18 months
or maybe even 15 months if you all get
bananas about it
i left out how much have you got in
shavings
i've got about 45 000. okay
and she has 50 and she has 55 000
in debt so if you write a check for 45
000 there's only 10 000 left right
okay well after you're married and uh
you're making a hundred thousand
so you should be debt-free in like two
months
this is the greatest call of your life
brother we've just solved all of your
problems
and then you're going to rebuild your
savings and she can't be nervous about
using up your savings because she's not
got any savings
so she's already should be nervous right
yes completely agreed and you brother
are going to have to work on the pronoun
problem
which is this is going to quickly become
not her debt but
y'all's debt our debt our debt our enemy
your savings our savings account power
savings that's right yeah when you are
married and come home from the honeymoon
the pronouns change you are now french
we
we do stuff now we do stuff together
that's right
it's not your stuff my stuff it's uh
unless the dog goes on the floor and
then it's your dog
other than that it's everything else
right
but uh oh my gosh that's your child
that's misbehaving that's right that's
right
that is your son that's actually a rule
my wife and i have
yeah whichever whichever he's standing
in the middle of the street peeing he's
your son whichever behavior
the the principal calls us on that
person's got to go to the god
you're john i'm just saying that's right
i agree with her on that part but
yeah no change your pronouns as soon as
you get married and you can say what
and you could even do that in the dream
meeting and say
how is life going to look like for us
right we what is it we're going to do
and what if we took
after marriage and applied 45 000 to 55
000 worth of debt
and in the meantime you work like crazy
and you've already paid it down
10 from working weekends and so when we
come home from the honeymoon we're like
debt-free how cool is that
that would be a dream that's better than
five years five years kind of sucks
yeah and your life right now kind of
sucks so maybe we can fix this thing
i think we need a bad dream not a bad
dream
we're going to put financial coaches and
counselors out of business if we solve
people's marriages like that man
now well i mean sharon and i were on
about our third date i was driving a
monte carlo with 285 000 miles on it
third engine second transmission i was
to say that's back when
yeah it was i mean i had driven this car
i it was on its third life
and i was explaining to her i had a
dollar sixteen in my checking account
and i was explaining to her how some day
i was gonna be a millionaire and about
that time we went across the railroad
tracks and muffler fell off my car
so this is this is the dream meeting
right the dream
this is the dream meeting what could
this look like and uh and you know the
strange part is the woman actually
believed me
hey and she was right that's right
because i'm so dumb i've done it twice
there you go a millionaire twice two
different times now oh my gosh
yeah that's that's that's the dream
meeting that's what you're doing and
it's okay if the muffler falls off the
car in the middle of the dream meeting
but just uh have it and sit down and
change your pronouns and start laying
out some math plans and start talking
about going through
maybe you go through ramsey plus during
this year uh while you're planning and
getting married and
finish up and revisit after the marriage
and that kind of stuff you'd have a
whole
year lined up to do all that very cool
man very cool